and I, I think both admire, Charlie
Kirk, uh, once said, he said, "Islam is
the sword the left is using to slit
of America." Do you agree with Charlie?
Cuz I do. Oh, you do? More like before
he was assassinated, yes, and Candace
Owens is exposing this by Israel, open
secret. And more like that statement
would have been, "Israel is the sword
the right used to slit the throat of
America."
This is One Ummah charity video. If you
care about the dunya more than your
akhira, skip it. By one donation, you're
going to help 1.8 million people in
need. 551,000 people who've been fed
through the emergency food aid. You are
going to be sponsoring 4,200 orphans.
You will be helping 250,000 people in
Gaza. You'll be helping 123,000
people to be fed through our Qurbani
program. You will help feed 551,000
people through the emergency food aid.
56 masjids that are going to be built
around the world. And 74,000 given
clean, safe water. That's why we want to
keep One Ummah 100% donation policy. And
in order for us to keep it 100, we need
you to help us by supporting this fund
so that all of the stuff that I
mentioned, you get the reward for every
single one of them. It's far more
important than the dunya. And you will
see every penny that you give on Yawm
al-Qiyamah. The decision is yours. The
link is there. Donate now. So, the
Zionist Jews are desecrating Jesus
statues, hitting it because they believe
that anyway, cuz they believe Jesus is
on his own, uh, burning his own feet,
and his mother is an adulterer. Why
would an Israeli soldier want to smash
the face of Jesus? This is a country,
we're often told, that is a safe haven
for Christians in the region. Well,
before any of those questions could be
answered, the Israeli media jumped in.
This does not look good at all for, uh,
the Israelis. And, uh, it's going to be,
uh, circulating online in the US as
well. We know, uh, who will, uh, take
advantage of this. Definitely Hezbollah
affiliated accounts. And this is, uh,
again, another incident that, uh, is
going to make a lot of lot of bad
portraying of the IDF. The problem with
an IDF soldier smashing the face of
Jesus is not that he smashed the face of
Jesus. The problem is that he got caught
on camera. And in fact, it turns out not
only did the guy who did it get
punished, but so did the guy who filmed
it because exposing what the IDF does to
the rest of the world is the real crime.
What you don't hear is any examination
of why it happened in the first place.
What does it reflect of the attitudes of
the Israeli military and of Israel
itself toward Christianity? That's never
addressed. And Patrick David has done a
video against Tucker Carlson asking him,
yes, why does he support the Sharia or
believes the Sharia has done good things
for the Muslim world. Has Hezbollah
blown up Christian holy sites? Has
Hezbollah targeted ambulances? No, they
haven't. In fact, the opposite.
Hezbollah was in fact protecting the
Christian churches and protecting the
symbolic areas of religious importance
to Christians. There's footage of them
going into churches and cleaning up and
tidying up and standing up, and you
know, protecting the Christian faith. If
you listen to the speeches of Hassan
Nasrallah, he said Hezbollah are the
main defenders of the Christian faith.
So no, they're not destroying
ambulances, they're not destroying
churches, they're not destroying
mosques, they're not destroying people's
homes, but Israel is, and it's doing it
with American and Western-supplied
weapons as well. And he talks about
experiences how Muslims are bad and
Islam is a danger to America. Let's
watch his reaction video, inshallah, for
ourselves. This is going to be
interesting.
Here's Patrick Bet-David on his podcast
a day or two ago. Watch this. I don't
know why Catholics, uh,
you know, have this issue with Jews. I
don't know what it is.
They have this this this,
you know, I I don't Listen, I get that
Jews have issues with Christians, and
they'll make fun, and they'll say stuff
like, "Oh, your Jesus is going to do You
know, they'll say, "Well, he was a Jew
anyways, right?"
But then Catholics have that issue with
Jews.
And they they act like, you know,
they're all innocent and everything. And
then when you look at Catholics, the
amount of centralized power they have.
Centralized. If you You know what the
total Catholic population is worldwide?
It's like 1.2, 1.3
billion. Jews are 15 million.
>> 15 million.
>> But Jews are decentralized.
Meaning, Catholic Jews don't have
somebody they listen to that says, "Hey,
you better do this."
Catholics, God forbid you say something
about the Pope. They're like, "Hey, man,
listen." Who is that Pope figure in the
Christian community? We don't have one.
>> um I can argue that that can make them
more dangerous. Because you think that
they don't have a central figure they
don't listen they listen to. Yes, they
do. Yes, they do.
You know, they have like for example the
Talmud, they have their rabbis. You
know, you might be thinking, you know,
um this is like, you know, uh
you know, like with the with the Jews
themselves, uh they are very um
they're very uniform in uniform. Yes,
you see all of them across board, they
have certain beliefs that they live by.
Gentiles and they the fact of their
hatred uh for the Christians. And you
have admitted that the Crusaders and the
Catholics have had problem with Jews,
which we're going to come back cuz it's
going to disprove your point. Let's
carry on. No. If I ask you right now,
who's the Pope in the Christian
community? You don't have somebody to
look at. Who is a Which pastor? Yeah,
exactly. No, they don't have
>> We don't have one. It's an independent
network of churches. But if you look at
only Catholics and Muslims have somebody
that they look at as their supreme
leader like, you know, you got to go to
somebody. But even more, it's Catholic.
>> only two theocracies in the world. W-
Catholicism and
>> I- Islam. I'm sorry, the the the uh
Islamic Republic of Iran and the
Vatican. Yeah. Those are the two major
theocracies. What the hell is he talking
about? Like seriously, what is he loves
it like uh Adam Adam loves when the
attention's gone from the Zionists. Yes,
let the Christians and Muslims fight
each other while we, you know, build our
third temple and the great Israel play
plan, etc. So, anyways, we can see right
through it.
So, actually, the Vatican is very much
like the Nazi
Iranian government, the theocratic
government, the mullahs, it's all
basically the same. They've got the
complicated dress, they hate the Jews,
as Patrick Bet-David just said, there's
Catholics have a problem with the Jews,
a problem with the Jews.
It's
slander.
It's an attack on the world's largest
and oldest Christian denomination, and
it's taking place openly.
And it's all
coming from the same source,
which is
Israel. The issue is Israel. Anyone who
supports the Netanyahu government, not
Israel as a concept, not all Jews, no,
the Netanyahu government, anyone who
ratifies every decision, no matter how
violent or grotesque or genocidal of the
Netanyahu government, those are the good
people, and anyone who doesn't is a
Nazi, and by the way, their religion
itself is a Nazi religion, it's an
inherently anti-Semitic religion.
>> Okay, so we're going to go to Patrick
Bet-David's response to Tucker Carlson,
and we're going to dissect that. But one
thing I have to disagree with Tucker
Carlson is
the Catholics and the Crusaders, they
had issues with the Jews. Because the
Jews were they they obviously they hide
what they actually believe about the
Christians um specifically the
Christians in the Holy Land, they don't
tell you, but they you see it by them
desecrating the
the um the statue of Jesus, you know,
which we're going to I'm going to show
you right in a minute, inshallah, where
Netanyahu is condemning. How do you
condemn something that your scripture
says? Okay, so here you can see that um
which is important that the Jews were
massacred by the Christians. They were,
and in history and anti-Semitism and the
word infidel comes from the Crusades and
the Christianism. Let's be real with
that. Okay, I'm not saying every
Catholic does that now, but that was the
main thing. Anti-Semitism comes from the
Crusades cuz they believe they killed
their God. Okay, and they would install
Jesus and his mother, etc. So, there was
deep hatred. Before we go to Patrick
Bet-David, let's just watch BBC showing
us how the IDF were desecrating the the
Christian Jesus
statue. The Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu has condemned an
Israeli soldier who hit a statue of
Jesus with a sledgehammer in southern
Lebanon.
The statue was mounted on a crucifix
outside a church in a Christian village
that had been occupied by Israeli
troops. Mr. Netanyahu has said he
regrets any hurt caused to Christian
believers in Lebanon and around the
world.
>> Interesting. Interesting. So, look,
they're doing that cuz that's idolatry
worship. They they are taught by their
faith that they should be
they should be doing this. You know
what's very funny? Hezbollah was
controlling those areas cuz they say IDF
is now controlling it.
But they never did that. They never
desecrated it. Hezbollah, yes, which you
believe say that if for Shia Islam or
whatever it's for the matter, they never
desecrated Jesus.
Hamas, who's controlling Gaza, etc.,
where there was churches that's been
there for centuries, have never ever
been desecrated their churches.
The IDF tanks were bombing the crosses.
So, let's see what Patrick Bet-David has
to say. Let's see if he got evidence.
But Tucker, it's interesting. I watched
this video a few times and respectfully
I want to respond to you because you're
you're a formidable voice. Whether I
agree with you or not, you're somebody
that's very good at getting your message
out there. And I think at this point,
you know, if there's anybody that
believes in your ability, it's a guy
like this who after I sold my company, I
gave offered you a $100 million
contract. I went I even went on your
friend Megyn Kelly's show
when I announced it and she was asking
specific questions. I said, "Yep, we
went to your house. We made the offer
then we spent some time together. I came
to Maine and
we did your show and we we've had we've
had a couple good conversations
together. Interesting. So, he's saying
that he believed in Tucker Carlson cuz
Tucker Carlson even 100 million pounds
he wanted to invest in I don't know what
he's talking about the house. Well, it
looks like he's somebody that believes
in Tucker Carlson. Okay. Let's see
what's changed.
>> So, I believe in you. I think you're
funny, quirky, very good communication,
and you have your way of doing things.
It's almost like a
you you do twist words a lot and I
noticed you did that with me. He hates
Catholics, you know, he hates this.
Catholics hate the Jews and all this
stuff that you did. It's a little bit of
a
uh you know, your stick which I get. Let
me kind of get into a few things I want
to address with you in this video and
maybe you're not aware of it.
Few things you need to know about me. My
number one priority
is to make sure America stays as the
greatest country in the world. Period.
Full stop. Okay, his main priority is
not Christianity. Is America has to be
the best country in the world.
Okay. Let's carry on. I'm America first.
I'm a Christian, non-denominational
Christian that you need to know about
me. And by the way, I'm Armenian, which
by the way, the first nation that
accepted Christianity as their religion
was Armenians. Yep, and and they did it
peacefully. You know, they said, "Yes,
we love Christ. Yes, yes." It wasn't cuz
of war. It wasn't cuz of the crusaders
came, you know. No, no, no, no, no. They
came peacefully. They said, "We love
Christ. Yes." Okay. And the only ones
that debate Armenians on them being
first is Assyrians and my dad is
Assyrian. Maybe that's the reason why my
parents divorced each other
uh twice, married each other, and
divorced each other. So, Armenian
Assyrian Christian America first. I want
this thing to be the greatest country in
the world. I want capitalism to be
common sense for everybody to realize
that if a new person wants to come up
and have their dreams become a reality,
I want that to be out there. But, I
wonder if that's where you are today.
Okay, let's see. Let's see So, yeah,
let's see he's contentious with Tucker
Carlson. Okay, here we go. We're going
to get into it. He believes in him. He's
a good guy, blah blah etc. You know, he
twists words here and there which he's
upset about, but let's see. You were
always there for many years until what's
happened with you the last couple years.
So, let me kind of address
a few things. So, you said something a
couple weeks ago. You said
um
Sharia law has made Islamic societies
more advanced than the West.
>> Interesting. So, he was good a couple of
years ago and something changed about
Tucker Carlson. What What something
changed? Because, you know, he's saying
his vision should be the same that
America first Christian country.
Okay. So, has Tucker Carlson changed or
Patrick Bet-David, you Chihuahua, or
have you changed and become a master to
the Zionists? Let's see. So, he has an
issue with what? That the statement that
Tucker Carlson made.
>> Huh.
It's interesting. Sharia law has made
Islamic societies more advanced than the
West.
It's a pretty bold statement.
I mean, it's like you're selling Sharia
law more than you're selling America.
Well, isn't that true? I mean, look at
it. The first university was
by a woman called Fatima who inherited
money from his father. When we look at,
for example, the invention that has been
done by the Muslim world, one of them is
your navigation that you have today.
Patrick Bet-David, when you go home or
wherever you're going, by Maryam
al-Asturlabi. Yes? Who learned from her
father the navigation system that Joe
Rogan looked and said, "If I saw this on
the road, I'd think it was done by
aliens." And that's how advanced it was.
It would tell you the prayer time,
astronomy, you needed a mathematics,
metal work. You needed to know so much
stuff to
put that together. It was a masterpiece.
The Muslim world has been advanced on a
golden age a thousand years ago when
later Joseph Saxton came and made his
little own version of it. So, yes, it
is. The Sharia not only
physically but spiritually and mentally
uplifts nations. And his issue with
Tucker Carlson is this. Okay, let's
carry on with this today. Because
they're saying he is really putting
America first. You, by getting Zionist
Israelis to send grape their American
children in the pedo islands and Epstein
islands. Yes? And then sending your
children to die for Israel. Or is Tucker
Carlson a true patriot? Trying to see
what you're solving for. See, this is
kind of where I'm at
with my life that most people don't know
about, but let me kind of share it with
you.
For 7 and 1/2 years I work with Mormons.
Guess what? I read everything I could on
Mormons and I realized it's not a
denomination for me. I'm not interested.
I watch all the videos you're you're not
supposed to watch. Ask me how many bad
experiences I had with Mormons. Zero.
Good. Perfect. When I saw this I was
like, good. This is going to lead to
this people that person's the Jews, the
Christians and it's going to come to
Islam and that's exactly you can look
watch where he goes. Mormons he had zero
bad experience. Good. They're phenomenal
people. I work with 7th Day Adventist
Adventist and I learned that on
Saturdays, you know, they're Saturday,
Sunday, all these different things on
very interesting. Guy named Juan Reavis,
big community. Not for me, but guess
what? I got along with them. Jews. I
noticed Jews when I do business with
them, it's very interesting if you
negotiate with them. They're going to be
very, very uh uh making sure they get
all the uh benefits on their side. But
ask me how many times I've had issues
with Jews. Interesting. Look at the way
he criticizes him. You know, they're
going to be you know, they they you
know, the negotiation they look out for
their self, you know, in that Torah
their books it tells them very clearly
they can charge interest to
the Gentiles, the like you, but
not amongst their selves. Interesting.
You know, but it's you know, they look
out for their self etc. But I've had a
bad experience with them? No. And well,
go and ask a Zionist Jew and ask them is
America first?
And see if Tucker Carlson is showing
you. Ask him is America first? They're
using you guys my friend. What are you
talking about? You Israeli shill. Never.
Okay, if you ask me about Catholics, I
built an insurance company with 60,000
insurance agents, 54% Hispanic and what
do you think most Hispanics are?
Catholics. Never had one issue with a
single Catholic in my life. And last but
not least.
>> Okay, good. Perfect. Catholics, Jehovah
Witnesses, 7th Day Adventists, Jews,
nada. Hindus, uh-uh.
Everyone's been fantastic
to Patrick Bet-David except last but not
least, Islam, Muslim. I lived with them
for 11 years. When you say Sharia law
has made Islamic societies more advanced
than the West, I lived with the IRGC and
the Hezbollah's in Iran. Ah, so he lived
with them in Iran. Yes? As a what? He
was hostile from with them from the from
the get-go. I don't support his the
regime in in in Iran. Yes? Okay. I'm not
saying I completely sure. Look, they're
they're doing what they want to do. It's
up to them. As long as they're not
killing innocent men, women, children,
etc. like Israel is doing, I don't have
an issue with them. My mother and my
sister were frightened to walk outside.
That's this guy. I lived with them,
okay? Not hypotheticals and you know, we
are now both very wealthy. You come from
a very wealthy family. I think you also
may have married into a wealthy family
and you made a lot of money. You made a
lot of money in your life and your
business is doing very well today. When
you go to dinner, you're having dinner
with people that are going to make sure
you see the best side of everything you
go to. When I went to Mumbai Ah,
interesting. So he's basically saying
that Tucker Carlson is going into
lunches and dinners with Muslims and
they're just putting a fake they're
faking it. They're faking it. Not that
the hospital people not all the people
non-Muslims traveling around Muslim
world and saying, "Man, we have never
got better hospitality than the
Muslims." Nope.
Tucker Carlson, the people that you're
around they're just doing taqiyya.
They're doing taqiyya. They showed me
the best part of Mumbai. I went to the
slums because I wanted to see what it
looked like. Whatever part of the world
I go to, I get treated royally today.
Why? Because they want to show me the
best. But I lived in the worst when our
family had nothing, literally nothing is
what we had when we lived in Iran. Okay,
good. So you had nothing. So what's your
personal subjective experience? What the
how do how does that prove anything,
bro? What the flipping are you talking
about? Regular places we lived in the
city of Tehran.
But you know, as crazy as that is
do you know my chef that lives with us?
When we go on the road, he's with us all
the time.
Do Do know he's Muslim and he's Turkish
and he's still a Muslim? Interesting.
Now, he as an Armenian, Syrian, yes,
okay. And he's Turkish.
It does not get Let me let me say
something. I It doesn't get worse than
that because they claim there was a
genocide done by the Armenians Armenians
by the Ottoman Empire, okay? That was
done towards them, which is disputed.
There's nothing factual about this.
Disputed, okay? So, let's see his chef
that cooks for him, bro, that cooks for
him the food that your family and kids
eat. He's Turkish and he's a Muslim. And
you still hire him. Okay, interesting.
Let's see what kind of experience you
had with him. And do you know what Turks
did to Armenians and Assyrians? You ever
heard of the Armenian genocide or the
Assyrian genocide? You ever heard of
that? 1 and 1/2 million, 300,000,
200,000?
I love this guy. Interesting. So, that's
a genocide, yeah? And there is nothing
established fact on it being a genocide.
If it is, we'll condemn it all day,
every day. We're consistent. Um
but what Israel's doing is not a
genocide. So, you are hurt by what
they've done to your people. You had
some bad experience in Iran. You hate
Islam.
But when the Palestinians are being
massacred, kicked out their own houses,
the whole world is watching 4K a
genocide.
Uh yeah, let's let's let's let's not
talk about that.
Let's not talk about Zionist Jews.
They're they're fine. They're good
people. They're good people. Look at the
utter hypocrisy. He's a great guy to us.
He's very good to us. Because I isolate
the relationship with that individual
and I still tell him how concerned I am
with what Islam could do to America.
Okay, hold on a sec. So, you isolate
your relationship with your chef who is
a
Turk, yes, an Ottoman Empire, okay? And
he's a Muslim. Bro, that's double
trouble.
Double trouble. And he's cooking for you
and your family and your kids.
And you say, "Yeah, I had no bad
experience with him." So, why doesn't
that represent Islam? He goes, "What? I
isolate my relationship with him."
Meaning, I take out Islam. What if he's
that good and whatever it is for that
matter because of Islam?
No. No. No. No. No. No.
I isolated his religion has nothing to
do with it. The Seventh-day Adventist,
the Catholic, the Jew, the Jehovah
Witness, the Hindu, the Sikh, and
everyone, it's the religion of lovely
people. Islam and my Muslim chef who's
Armenian, I isolate myself. I am still
concerned of that of what's happened in
many different societies. Look at, you
know, what they're doing in Minnesota,
many markets that we read about. Look at
what's going on in New York right now.
Look at what's going on in a couple
places in Plano
on how they're growing. And so Charlie
Kirk who How they're growing? So how
does that make them bad? So because
they're growing in population, that
makes them bad? I don't understand.
Look what they're doing in Minnesota and
New York and they're and they're growing
and etc. whatever and then unless they
some of them are bad bad bad.
So that makes them bad.
Are they massacring children? Committing
genocide? No. So you are concerned about
that, the America the Muslims in
Minnesota, New York, etc. They do
nothing close to what Israel's doing,
but with Israel
America first and they are you see these
guys, is Israel first for them?
You have you have you have no issue. You
And I I think both admire
Charlie Kirk uh uh
once said, yeah, I think it was 2 days
before he was killed. I think it was 1
day before he was killed. He said,
"Islam is the sword the left is using to
slit the throat of America." Let me read
it to you one more time. "Islam
is the sword the left is using to slit
the throat of America." Do you agree
with Charlie? Cuz I do. Oh, you do? More
like before he was assassinated, yes,
and Candace Owens is exposing this by
Israel, yes, open secret, yes.
Uh more like that statement uh would
have been I don't even know uh you know,
um it would have been
uh more like Israel is the sword the
right used to slit the throat of
America. And that's exactly Now, this
statement is saying it can't be
substantiated.
Israel with their lobbying AIPAC and
controlling America
and everything that they're doing and
sending your kids raping your kids in
Ireland
to blackmail the elite to send Trump to
war with Iran for their own gains and
benefits is nobody but Israel. If
there's anyone that's meddling and
interfering with your affairs
globally
is Israel. If there's anyone that's
desecrating your scripture and your holy
places is Israel. How is it that under
Hamas
and Hezbollah
Hezbollah, yes, which I'm
totally against Hezbollah what they've
done to the Sunnis in Israel.
They have protected the Christians more
than
you Christians could ever do.
So, who's actually putting America
first? Tucker Carlson or you? Tucker
Carlson there every day because he's
been consistent in saying these people
yes
have been meddling
for example, them being involved
attacking the Liberty USS Liberty ship,
trying to hush them. The laughing
Israelis when the 9/11 was happening,
JFK
assassination, Charlie Kirk, etc. And
you name it throughout history getting
involved and meddling, who is it?
Who is it?
It's all that needs to be said. And
Islam as a civilization, wherever it
went, it enriched it. It didn't go and
steal the diamonds and the, you know,
the the diamonds and, you name it, the
gold and the the resources bring it back
to Mecca. Yes? Okay. But the Western
world did that.
That's all I have to say about this,
inshallah. Tucker Carlson has
embarrassed and humiliated this coward.
This is one almost sadaqah jariyah
video. If you care about the dunya more
than the akhirah, skip it. By one
donation, you're going to help 1.8
million people in need. 551,000 people
who've been fed through the emergency
food aid. You are going to be sponsoring
4,200 orphans. You will be helping
250,000 people in Gaza. You'll be
helping 123,000
people to be fed through our Qurbani
program. You will help feed 551,000
people through the emergency food aid.
56 masjids that are going to be built
around the world. And 74,000 given clean
safe water. That's why we want to keep
One Ummah 100% donation policy. And in
order for us to keep 100, we need you to
help us by supporting this fund so that
all of the stuff that I mentioned, you
get the reward for every single one of
them. It's far more important than the
dunya. And you will see every penny that
you give on your mawqif the day of
resurrection.